[Musik]
der herr den ihr sprechen sich das ist
der sprecher der iranischen regierung
war sie so was wie der steffen seibert
der mullahs auf dieser pressekonferenz
spricht er darüber wie super sein land
die korona virus solche unter kontrolle
haben die iraner hätten rein gar nichts
zu befürchten es gebe nicht das
allerkleinste problem und der mann der
neben ihm steht und schwitzt das ist der
stellvertretende gesundheitsminister und
falls ihr euch jetzt fragt warum nur
schwitzt der gute mann so dann könnt ihr
euch dies verraten er hat fieber und am
nächsten tag wurde er positiv auf cobit
19 getestet diese bilder stammen aus dem
februar 2020 zu diesem zeitpunkt ist der
iran bereits eines der am stärksten von
corona virus betroffenen länder
offizielle zahlen entsprechen zum
zeitpunkt als wir dieses video drehen
sonst noch 5000 bis fällen aber es
könnten noch viel mehr sein der iran ist
eines der länder das am langsamsten auf
die kampagne reagiert hat obwohl es
recht früh getroffen
das patolla regime hat sogar die
hilfsorganisation ärzte ohne grenzen aus
dem land geschlossen aus einem land das
praktisch von der welt abgeschnitten ist
was läuft da also im iran ab welche
schaden kann das land durch des corona
virus erleiden könnte dies am ende zum
untergang des regimes führen
[Applaus]
[Musik]
das jahr 2020 sinkt für das iranische
regime bereits katastrophal an zuerst
ließ donnerstag ihren job generals oder
mali mit einem drohnenangriff tötet mich
dann entschlossen die verwirrten truppen
der mullahs aber aus versehen ein
passagierflugzeug der ukraine airlines
nur knapp nach seinem start vom
teheraner flughafen ab und jetzt auch
noch das corona wird
die radroute eine katastrophale zahl von
todesopfern
zum zeitpunkt der aufnahme dieses videos
sind bereits 23 abgeordnete infiziert
und mehrere kilos beamte gespann in der
stadt ghom müssen massengräber
ausgehoben werden um die hunderten von
leichen zu begraben und ich weiß was
viele von euch mails sagen werden etwas
ähnliches spielte sich doch auch
entspannen in italien und new york und
ja ihr habt recht im fall irans ist
dieses jedoch besonders ernst denkt
darüber nach dieses land befindet sich
seit mehr als zwei jahren in einer
brutalen wirtschaftskrise die durch dann
als tramp verhängten
wirtschaftssanktionen haben das ganze
land fast vollständig isoliert dass der
iran kann kaum atemschutzgeräte masken
und medizinische ausrüstung kaufen die
bei einem solchen raketen haften anstieg
des bedarfs benötigt er
zwar stimmt ist dass die
wirtschaftssanktionen medizinische
produkte nicht betreffen aber die preise
dafür sind gerade überall extrahiert der
iran verfügt kaum noch über diesen
quellen
vielleicht erinnert euch daran die wir
in einem anderen video darüber
gesprochen haben wie der iran vom switch
system isoliert wurde dem system das
internationale zahlungstransaktionen
ermöglicht weil sie das video nicht
kennt könnt ihr es euch über den link
ansehen da jetzt boden erscheint oder
der in der beschreibung unter dem video
steht kurz gesagt der iran hat kaum
möglichkeiten seine kranken zu behandeln
und sein medizinisches personal zu
schützen in dieser situation wäre es
doch normal um hilfe zu bitten oder
andere länder oder einfach unabhängige
hilfsorganisationen denn in einer
krisensituation sollten wir uns doch
alle zusammen schließen und alte
differenzen überwinden nicht war nun das
regime in teheran sieht das anders
[Musik]
iranische behörden verweigern ersten
ohne grenzen die genehmigung für ein
crooner virus behandlungszentrum ihr
habt richtig gehört der iran verweigerte
hilfe einer unabhängigen internationalen
hilfsorganisationen sie haben auch
jegliche hilfe aus den usa abgelehnt das
iranische regime will die korona virus
krise unbedingt einzig und allein aus
eigener kraft lösen
aber die wahrheit ist dass sie dafür
keinen klaren aktionsplan haben italien
zum beispiel hat sich eine landesweite
auslandsstart verordnet als dort 9000
menschen positiv getestet waren spanien
erklärte den alarmzustand bei 5200
andere länder die sehr vorsichtig waren
wie zum beispiel tschechien begann mit
der umsetzung von maßnahmen als sie noch
nicht mal 100 positiv getestete
vorzuweisen hatten nun zum zeitpunkt des
drehs dieses videos sprechen offizielle
zahlen aus dem iran von mehr als 78.000
bestätigten infektionen mit profit 19
und die regierung hat noch keine
einigung maßen anfassen
einer der hauptgründe die wirtschaft der
iran ist seit jahren praktisch pleite in
dieser situation ist das letzte was sie
wollen das wenig produktiv wirtschaft
dass ihnen noch übrig geblieben ist
anzuhalten aber zu welchem preis die
frage lautet also ob sie zumindest in
der lage sein werden ihre wirtschaft zu
retten wenn sie schon das virus sich
frei ausbeuten lassen wird dich für die
ein tolles ausgehen bevor wir diese
fragen angehen wollen wir wie immer
zuerst ein wenig ihnen die geschichte
bieten
[Musik]
ein starkes land ich werde euch eine
frage stellen welche aktienmarkt ist
2009 10 am stärksten gewachsen einige
werden sagen new york singapur der dax
nun keine davon
die antwort lautet die teheraner börse
ja richtig gehört die iranische börse
ist im vergangenen jahr kicken haft
gewachsen wie aber war das möglich schon
das jahr 2009 10 ist für den iran doch
schrecklich verlaufen nur euch eine
vorstellung zu geben 2018 exportierte
dieses land noch drei millionen barrel
erdöl pro tag ein jahr später waren
exporte auf weniger als eine halbe
million besucher all dies ist ob die
sanktion zurückzuführen die die
vereinigten staaten eint haben
sanktionen die auch europäische
unternehmen zum verlassen des landes 2
[Musik]
[Applaus]
vodafone oder stevens mussten alle ihre
investitionen im iran aufgeben die
inflationsrate überstieg 140 pro jahr
viele preise verdoppelten sich von einem
jahr aufs andere
die regierung musste die steuern massiv
erhöhen iraner ging auf die straße um
das regime schlug die proteste blutig
nieder was für ein debakel für die
wirtschaft und das ganze land doch in
jeder krise gibt es menschen die von ihr
profitieren und einer der großen
nutznießer dieser geschichte war die
iranische börse
[Applaus]
denkt mal darüber nach die iranische
regierung der reale wurde weniger wert
als monopoly geld und niemand hat lust
dass seine ganzen ersparnisse auf dem
konto oder unter dem kopfkissen
vollkommen entwertet werden was haben
die iraner also mit ihren sparguthaben
angestellt genau an der einzigen börse
investiert die ihnen einen so stark
isoliert ein land zur verfügung stehen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
aber nicht nur das die regierung wollte
um jeden preis die abhängigkeit vom öl
beenden und in gewisser weise hatte sie
erfolg tja liebe zuschauer der iran hat
der welt viel mehr zu bieten als fässer
voller öl schaut euch zum beispiel die
plastik umhüllung des kabels eures handy
ladegerät an nun diese ist ostpolitik
oder iran ist einer der hauptlieferanten
von politik gelehrt nach china wenn also
euer handy ladegerät mitentscheider ist
dann ist der kunststoff auf dem kabel
mit in iran aber nicht nur das in einem
anderen video haben wir euch bereits vom
chor der nationalen automarke des iran
erzählt denn ja der iran stellt seine
eigenen autos durch die abwesenheit von
konkurrenz durch große internationale
marken wie nokia ist coco im iran enorm
gewachsen die herstellung ist von 600
auf über 2.000 autos pro tag gestiegen
natürlich mit der hilfe der regierung
und natürlich wurden diese autos in die
nachbarländer exportiert länder wie irak
am medien oder aserbaidschan um die
sanktionen zu umgehen sind viele
iranische geschäftsleute mit koffern
voller geldscheine in die türkei gereist
um dort unternehmen zu tun von der
türkei aus könnten sie internationale
zahlungstransaktionen durchführen und
ihre produkte verkaufen allein im jahr
2009 gründeten iranische geschäftsleute
2000 unternehmen auf türkischem boden
aber auch in vielen anderen bereichen
wird eine enorme konsolidierung in
richtung autarkie also eine
unabhängigkeit von importen statt nach
angaben des waren im schnitt 1 während
70 prozent der im iran verwendeten
medizinischen geräte im land selbst
hergestellt mit anderen worten ja die
exporte des iran sind stark
zurückgegangen aber mithilfe von china
und seinen nachbarländern konnte der
iran über die runden kommt natürlich
handelt es sich um eine
subsistenzwirtschaft aber es hätte ja
auch noch viel schlimmer kommen können
tja und dann kam es mir schlimmer
der mini in der heiligen stadt
die stadt ghom ist in der wichtigsten
heiligen stätten des schiitischen islam
jedes jahr besuchen mehr als 20
millionen pilger den schreien der fatima
hast du mal in diese stadt baut china
eine anbindung für
hochgeschwindigkeitszüge und ein
gigantisches solarkraftwerk ok und warum
erzähle ich euch davon nun am 14 februar
2020 hat der iran alle flüge nach und
aus china gestrichen um eine infektion
mit dem kronau virus zu verhindern die
regierung drückte jedoch bei einer
fluggesellschaft machen eher ein auge zu
und wir euch vorstellen könnt war daher
nicht in der lage chinesische
geschäftsleute vom fliegen abzuhalten
[Musik]
aber das ist noch nicht alles am 15
februar hielt ein toller kanada eine
religiöse versammlung in eben jener
stadt goma im prinzip verliest alles
ganz normal bis auf eine sache daher
toller erlaubte niemandem seine hand zu
küssen und ihr werdet uns sicher fragen
musste er dann etwas was andere nicht
wussten ja das tat er
[Musik]
es stellte sich heraus dass nicht
weniger als 700 schiitische geistliche
chinesische herkunft an diesen
veranstaltungen teilnahmen und nur vier
tage später bestätigte die regierung die
ersten beiden todesfälle mit coop 19 in
der stadt ghom nach angaben von
lokalpolitikern waren diese todesfälle
bereits seit mehreren tagen bekannt wie
ihr euch vorstellen könnt begann sich
die iraner zu diesem zeitpunkt schon
sorgen zu machen
am 24 februar gab der regierungssprecher
eine pressekonferenz auf dieser
pressekonferenz sagte er es gebe keinen
grund zur sorge die regierung hätte das
corona virus unter kontrolle und es
bestünde keine notwendigkeit für eine
garantie der stellvertretende
gesundheitsminister der ihn zur seite
stand zeigte jedoch bereits die ersten
symptome von kuwait prozent das virus an
sich wurde offenbar nicht als die
hauptbedrohung angesehen denn die
regierung kuranyi hatte alle hände voll
zu tun um das eindringlichste aller
probleme im falle einer schrecklichen
pandemie zu bekämpfen
am 29
februar verhaftete die cyber polizei 24
menschen wegen der verbreitung von
angeblichen falschmeldungen und
verschwörungstheorien währenddessen
widersprachen sich die iranischen
behörden ständig erinnert ihr euch zum
beispiel an den stand der fatima bei dem
wir vorher gesprochen haben nun der
direktor dieses heiligtum street
weiterhin alle schiitischen pilger auf
zu kommen und zu beten
sein argument war welcher ort ist besser
geeignet um geheilt zu werden als ein
heiliger schreien
inzwischen gab es im iran offiziell 245
positiv getestete die sich fast alle in
der stadt ghom befanden
der bürgermeister bat darum die stadt
schließen zu dürfen aber die regierung
reagierte nicht zumindest gab es keine
klare antwort zum einen sagte romani er
erwäge das gesamte land unter quarantäne
zu stellen aber noch nicht interessen
nahm die zahl der bestätigten fälle
weiter zu aber einen namen
dies war nicht das größte problem denkt
daran dass der iran seit zwei jahren
vom internationalen markt abgeschnitten
ist wenn europäische länder schon kaum
atemschutzmasken und tests kaufen können
stellt euch ein land vor dass nicht
einmal geld ins ausland überweisen kann
und hier kommt er ins spiel die usa
[Musik]
die amis sind an allem schuld
wer hat den iran von den internationalen
märkten isoliert die vereinigten staaten
von amerika und wer kann den iran helden
atemschutzmasken und corona wer ist es
zu beschaffen die vereinigten staaten
von amerika als ich es erklärt warum
außenminister mike kompon angeboten hat
dem iran zu helfen unterdessen
diskutierte der us-kongress die
möglichkeit die sanktionen gegen die
iran aufzunehmen
die wahrheit aber ist dass dies alles
sowieso keine rolle gespielt hat daniela
kammerer hatte bereits eine entscheidung
getroffen
[Musik]
der iranische staatschef lehnte hilfe
der usa ab und beruft sich auf eine
verschwörungstheorie ayatollah ali
khamenei behauptet das virus unter
verwendung genetischer daten von iranern
speziell dazu entwickelt wurde um dem
iran zu schaden ja genau das hat er
gesagt falls sie jemand an der quelle
zweifelt die nachrichten stammen von al
jazira einem sender aus katar das ist
alles andere als tehran feindlich
eingestellt ist und ich weiß dass viele
von euch jetzt denken man dafür wird es
doch irgend eine rationale erklärung
geben schließlich ist es normal dass der
iran den usa nicht vertraut aber dann
kommt zur überraschung aller auch meiner
selbst diese nachricht iranische
behörden verweigern ersten ohne grenzen
die genehmigung für ein corona virus
behandlungszentren ich meine erste ohne
grenzen ist eine hilfsorganisation des
sitz in der schweiz
sie helfen mit humanitären missionen in
der ganzen welt baum wird ihre hilfe vom
iran abgelehnt die einzige logische
erklärung das ist dass man doch irgend
etwas großes zu stop motion hat was
könnte das sein nun haltet euch fest
toiletten bilder zeigen dass der iran in
mitten des corona virus ausbruchs
massengräber angelegt hat nun
massengräber an sich sind schon eine
schlimme sache aber man muss verstehen
dass massengräber gegen die gebote des
islam verstoßen und in dieser region der
welt eigentlich etwas unerhörtes
darstellen und anfang märz tauchte dann
auch noch ein handy video auf das
enormen des hauptes von gott gesandt
worden war
auf diesem war zu sehen wie sich
dutzende von leichen in den dortigen
aufbewahrungsräume stellen und schon
seit tagen auf ihre beerdigung waren
scheinbar waren die kapazitäten des
friedhofs einfach erschöpft der
friedhofsmitarbeiter von denen diese
aufnahmen stammen sagte in diesem video
es handelt es sich allesamt um corona
tote und das video verbreitete sich
sofort ebenso wie rar wie cupid 19 und
mit ihnen die wut über die zustände der
im islam ist ist besonders wichtig dass
mit leichen respektvoll umgegangen wird
diese eine dreifache waschung mit wasser
erhalten und dann so schnell wie möglich
unter ausübung vorgeschriebener gebetet
begraben werden oder auch hier war es
für die regierung scheinbar am
wichtigsten erstmal den
friedhofsmitarbeiter zu verhaften und
die verbreitung des videos nicht des
virus mit aller härte zu unterbinden ja
alles sieht nach einer regelrechten
menschlichen katastrophe aus okay aber
ist es denn regime dann zumindest
gelungen die wirtschaft zu retten nun
die wahrheit ist neid die wenigen
verdienen handelspartner des iran haben
ihre grenzen zu dem land dicht gemacht
und ja das schließt sogar schnell mit
ein als ob das noch nicht genug wäre hat
die regierung am ende verboten von einer
stadt in die andere zu reisen mit
anderen worten die iranische wirtschaft
wird sowieso zum stillstand kommen und
was passiert mit dem regime wird
ayatollah khamenei sein image retten
können nun ali khamenei ist 80 jahre alt
das bedeutet dass er zur
hauptrisikogruppe für cupid 19 gehört
und während das regime alles tut um ihn
vor einer ansteckung zu schützen gibt es
dinge die einfach schwer zu vermeiden
sind
[Musik]
eine parade des obersten führers des
iran mit dem corona virus infiziert nun
stellt sich die frage wie wird der iran
nach dieser krise aussehen
glaubt ihr dass dies das ende des
ayatollah regimes einleiten könnte warum
lehnt das land jegliche internationale
hilfe derart vehement ab bitte
hinterlasst eure von uns so hoch
geschätzten meinungen wie immer im
kommentarbereich unter diesem video wenn
euch dieses video gefallen hat halt das
bitte mit euren freunden gibt uns ein
like und vergesst nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren und auch das glocken zum wohl
zu klicken um irak ein neues video mehr
zu verpassen was gut und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]